well the world's creepiest porn lawyer
has gotten very famous recently by
attacking Donald Trump's personal
attorney Michael Cohen that's probably
been good for his business
on the downside all this has invited
heightened scrutiny of his own past
business ventures Chris Gallagher has
more on that
Tracy I took her when Tully's Coffee
went Baker up five years ago Michael a
vanadis investment firm bought the
company at auction for just over nine
million dollars since then the Seattle
Times says a vanadis company has been
named in more than 50 state and federal
complaints including commercial lawsuits
and warrants for unpaid taxes Washington
State lawyer David Knowles says I would
not had carried out an illegal pump and
dump scheme where he ran the Tully's
coffee shops with held state and federal
taxes from his employees but then didn't
pay his state and federal taxes avenatti
responds by denying the claims and
calling David Knoll to quote unethical
hack of a lawyer despite the fact that
Washington State Bar Association says
Nold has no record of ethical or other
violations but Michael avenatti also
claims Tully's Coffee has long been
under new ownership and yet in court
testimony last year avenatti reportedly
listed himself as the chairman and
principal of Tully's and now we know
avenatti hasn't just faced business tax
liens we found records dating back 7
years of personal tax liens both state
and federal for 1.5 million dollars
including a $300,000 federal tax lien
from just three months ago Tucker
big lien trace thanks quick programming
note last night we mentioned the creepy
porn lawyer you just been hearing about
the one you've seen on TV recently
threatening people and it got us
thinking so we checked according to the
Washington free beacon between March 7th
and yesterday that guy appeared on CNN
and MSNBC a hundred and eight times
that's according to one source the real
number could be higher than that anyway
it's a lot of CNN and MSNBC and we
thought we would add a little diversity
to his media diet diversity of course
being our strength
so we invited the creepy porn lawyer
onto this show we called his office or
what he said was this office it may have
been a booth at a Wendy's in Passaic
maybe a White Castle you never know in
any case he turned us down flat too bad
would have been fun maybe when Jeff
Zucker tires of him over at CNN he will
reconsider our offer that won't be long
we'd enjoy it
instead tonight we're joined by someone
who was not an actual porn lawyer but
has closely followed the career of the
guy we were just talking about Julien
Epstein is a former chief counsel to
Democrats in the House Judiciary
Committee and he joins us tonight
Julien thanks a lot for coming on serve
evening Gege
there's a bit of a disconnect here the
argument from Democrats from day one has
been that President Trump is too shady
to be President in order to make that
case they're now using a creepy porn
lawyer with the history of financial
problems is he really the best standard
bearer for your message would you say
well III think Michael avenatti has been
effective on television I think he's
been effective in in advancing the
interests of his client and he's used
television much more effectively than
most lawyers do I'm not sure he is the
standard bearer for Democrats I think he
has I think the stormy Daniels issue to
be honest I think essential consultants
I think is a sideshow I think there
there is nothing an essential
consultants story that we know where
there's any laws that are necessarily
broken but I think there are relevant
questions that should be asked about was
essential consultants being used for a
Russian slush fund a campaign finance
slush fund for laundering money a lots
of things that people have kind of been
breathlessly alleging but there's no
evidence of I think there's questions
right yeah there's no evidence of any
legal violation but I don't realize the
central issue I still think if I can
just finish the point that the central
question here for Democrats far as
Democrats are concerned is whether the
president knew or was actively involved
in Martian interference in any way and
there's no evidence of that I'm not
saying there's ever the I think that is
a central question there's no evidence
more than a year in maybe we're gonna
find out that he teamed up with Putin to
steal the election from Hillary probably
not gonna find that out but for the
point right now it's all about the
creepy poor
and I'm wondering like what exactly is
the point of this I don't know what the
interests of his client are I don't know
who he represents I do know I'd be very
uncomfortable if you got ahold of my
confidential bank records wouldn't you
well I think we need to find out how we
got the information for sure I think
there were questions there but to be
honest Tucker I think your your
indictment is of the industry that
you're a participant in which is the
cable television industry I think it is
the obsession of the cable television
industry I think Bob Muller and the
Democrats for their part cable responds
to ratings I don't think he's been on
this channel as I just said we tried to
have him on the show cuz I I want to
meet this guy he and he should write
come on this I think would be in music
his help but he's too busy on the other
channels whose viewers are responding
that's why Jeff suckers put him on you
know every day for two months so he
really is one of the most famous
Democrats in America is a partisan
Democrat he worked on Democratic
campaigns dozens of them so what does
that tell you but I don't think that's
where the Democratic Party is right now
I mean I think what avenatti is doing is
relevant because it gets to whether
there were campaign finance violations
with the stormy Daniels payment it gets
to whether essential consultants was
being misused as a Russian slush fund as
a campaign finance like what expertise
does he have see like a Russian speaker
or an expert on
I don't want to get off subject but
essential consultants Michael Cohen's
law firm was had a client whose
principal beneficiary whose principal
benefactor II was a Russian oligarch
connected to Putin right now our
questions are to make another point yeah
because I don't think that he is a
standard bearer for Democrats I think
what Democrats are saying is not
impeachment not that Trump violated
criminal laws but let's get the facts on
the table we know that people around
Trump okay no I was considered to be
Russian a yes you were almost no
evidence that Trump did that right and
maybe we'll find out again that you know
he teamed up a brain but
q one last question and please answer
honestly
picture yourself standing in your
kitchen at night getting one last glass
of water from the kitchen sink and you
look at it to the backyard and there's
creepy porn lawyer how do you respond
well I live in an apartment building so
I don't think I'd be able to see him if
I look let's see you seem in the alley
outside how do you respond with your gut
reaction you see that guy in your
backyard how do you respond I I would
invite avenatti in because I'd have a
lot of questions I'd like to talk about
if I saw anybody on our side my eye if I
saw anybody outside my kitchen when I
was having my last glass of water at
night of course I would be creeped out
so as would you of course I would but
he's not raising raising some I'm just
raising some important questions I think
thanks for joining us I appreciate it